people argue with me about mentors no
just use your own gut feeling is that
how you learn English when you were two
years old you use your gut feeling to
start conjugating verbs no you learn
from other people you can learn from
their success even if you are in a
totally different industry because
success leaves Clues across all
industries I'm notorious for just cold
calling people win yeah just pick up the
phone call them up and let's just talk
rise and shine it since preso time
what's up believe nation it's evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have Michael Jordan level
talent at something and I want you to
find it embrace it and use it to make a
difference in the world so let's start
your day off right grab your coffee and
sip on today's message find mentors over
to you Tai Lopez the [ __ ] that people
argue with me on this reading thing and
people argue with me about mentors no
just use your own gut feeling is that
how you learn English when you were 2
years old you use your gut feeling to
start conjugating verbs no you learn
from other people you learn manners you
learn language you learn all things
valuable you learn to drive from another
person so it doesn't it make sense you
learn life so books are just the mentors
who maybe are dead now you won't learn
about Steve Jobs you ain't alive to
teach it but you can learn through
accumulated wisdom and that's what trust
me
I meet I very few powerful businessman
I've ever met
don't read a lot Warren Buffett who I
think's the best businessman by far in
the world because doesn't see has 75
companies that he pretty much runs 200
billion in revenue he reads 8 hours a
day
he reads 600 he said he slowed down in
his old age he only reads 500 pages a
day Bill Gates goes on reading vacations
Mark Zuckerberg just start started a
reading once a week book club on
Facebook and already got a couple
million far and now with audiobooks
there's no excuse you got YouTube videos
let this thing run in the background
like you want to become like a super
computer readers
download smart crap from smart people
and you pick and choose like some people
or like Thai I don't agree with
everything you say I'm like good I don't
agree with everything I said like a year
later I'm like wait I was wrong I see
people making fun of the Kardashians I'm
like you gonna make fun of the
Kardashians look Kylie Jenner the
youngest Kardashian in the last 18
months has done four hundred million
dollars in revenue on lipstick kits and
various make up things with Kylie
cosmetics put that in perspective
Lauria maybelline massive brands it took
them 50 years as an organization with
thousands of employees to do a Kylie
Jenner did by herself at 20 at 18 you're
gonna laugh at the Kardashians do you
have to agree with everything the
Kardashians know but like Abraham
Lincoln said I learned from everybody
even if sometimes it's what not to do so
you can just go into the Kardashians
reverse-engineer their success go I like
this I like this I like this I don't
like that then leave out what you don't
want if there was one hack to shortcut
in your path to success it would be to
find mentors to learn from people who
have already done what you're trying to
do instead of trying to come up with
every single solution yourself this is
the thing that saved my company when I
was 19 years old I had my first software
company I was struggling I was making
$300 a month barely able to survive
feeling terrible about myself
having no self-confidence no self-worth
feeling like a disgraced human being
feeling this the smallest possible shell
of of a human being that I could ever
feel that was me when I was 19 years old
I told my business partner that I quit I
cried my face off that night and I woke
up and I just told myself I'm not the
first guy to try to solve this before
like somebody's figured out how to have
success in a software company why am I
trying to do everything myself and Bill
Gates saved my company I'm so grateful
I've never met him in person yet there's
still some time which is great I looked
at how does Bill Gates make his first
million dollars not how does he make
another million dollars now that's not
interesting to me you know he's already
billionaire how do I go from 0 to 1
that's all I cared about at the
beginning and he did it through
partnerships and I applied that strategy
to my business and within
a little bit of time I had my first deal
my first partnership deal I had 13 and a
half thousand dollars in the bank up
front and it blew my mind I'm making
$300 a month I don't know how I'm gonna
survive and I got a deal for 13 and a
half K is the most money I've ever seen
that may not sound like a lot of money
right now but to me that was that was I
won the lottery I won the jackpot I was
eating you know beans for lunch every
day and celebrating a client deal with
McDonald's french fries because I
couldn't afford the entire meal so to
get 13.5 thousand dollars up front for a
partnership deal was was crazy it was
amazing and more importantly than that I
had won a way to go get more partnership
deals so I could I could replicate this
and get more money up front and to just
that idea of unlocking success by
modeling the people that had come before
me it's not gonna take you all the way
and what Bill Gates did didn't work a
hundred percent for me but it took me
80% of the way 90 percent of the way I
just had to modify it to fit my business
and my strategy so it's the single
biggest unlock to be able to grow your
company quickly to achieve whatever goal
you have quickly learn from the people
their successes and failures who have
come before you so now how do I do it
great having get a mentor how do how do
I go out and do it I'm gonna give you
three tips first off for the local
mentors the local mentors the people in
your community they might be part of
your family they might be part of your
church they might be part of your high
school or your university alumni there
might be friends of friends of friends
get the word out that you are trying to
do this kind of business or you're
looking try to grow in this area and
does anybody know anybody a friend of a
friend a mother of a friend the cousin's
brother something like something out
there there are people around you in
your local community if you started
asking that you're looking for help in
this area that they will support you
I will definitely tap into the networks
again so look at your church group if
you're part of a church group look at
any community or clubs you're a part of
definitely tap into your school network
high school alumni the University Alumni
they love helping and giving back so
finding that local mentor is a great
first step way number two my personal
favorite aspirational mentors these are
people who you have never met may never
meet I've got some of them all the wall
behind me I will never meet this man or
that man because they're both gone but
they've taught me a lot
and so I would look at two kinds of
aspirational mentors one people who are
in your industry who have accomplished a
lot
Bill Gates was in my industry software I
could learn from him to grow you know
Les Brown is my hero from a speaking
perspective young Les Brown so I can
learn by watching his speeches and his
programs and his courses to better
myself whoever has done what you're
trying to do yes you'll still have to
modify it again to fit your needs and
strategy but you can get 80 90 percent
of the way by modeling what worked for
them and then to I would just look at
the people who you look up to who are
not in the industry you know if you love
Kanye West you love Oprah Winfrey or you
love Levine Jane or whoever it is you
can learn from their success even if you
are in a totally different industry
because success leaves Clues across all
industries why do I feature Michael
Jordan in this channel or why mine I
feature a singer or painter or an
inventor because the lessons are the
same Jordan okay we're not going to
learn how to dunk I'm not gonna feature
that on my channel but everything around
his work ethic and how he worked was the
team and how he prepares all of that
stuff is still highly relevant and the
reason that pick people who you love is
because you will look up to them and
you're more likely to take the advice
even though Jordan might be saying the
exact same thing as jobs you may not
like jobs and so you'll ignore his
message but if Jordan's telling it to
you you're gonna listen to it that's why
features so many people from different
backgrounds because I'm hoping to hit
you with the same message over and over
and over and over and over and over and
over again that hopefully because
somebody said it is finally gonna stick
with you if you need to hear it from
Kanye and you won't hear it from jobs
awesome as long as you get the message
and so looking at aspirational mentors
who are in your field have done a lot or
two are people who you just look up to
study their stories their inspiration
for you and they can also give you the
tactics on what to do to grow your
business and three is online mentors
it's never been easier to get access to
people who have experience you can ask a
specific question - I go live almost
every day of the week every weekday I'm
live I'm right now for days live on
Instagram one day live on YouTube come
ask me a question I had Stephen Kelly on
my channel we answer questions every
month he's a CEO of a giant corporation
to billion dollars you have a question
you want to get
help come on it's free ask us questions
Tai Lopez goes live asking questions
this is your chance like it's never been
easier to get access to these people
follow them on all the platforms follow
them on Twitter on snapchat on Instagram
on YouTube when they have something that
goes live you want to be a part put your
hand up it's crazy how many people at
the beginning of one of these sessions
don't put their hands up and then by the
end everybody's put in their hand up be
the first go with intention know that
I'm going live know that Tai is going
live know that whoever you look up to is
going live at this time pay attention to
their events be there first be welcoming
have a great attitude say hi to
everybody and ask your question
ASAP look this is your chance I wish I
had this opportunity to number of people
who are 13 14 15 years old who popping
on my live chats and asked me questions
where I was 13 14 15 had to go to the
library to get answers this is amazing
so that's your chance to be able to get
access to online mentors to answer the
specific questions that you are going
through now I have a special bonus clip
I think you're gonna enjoy but before
that I want to know question the day who
is your biggest mentor who has helped
you out the most whether it's a local
aspiration or online mentor who has been
the biggest help show them some love
give them some exposure in the youtube
comments below thank you guys so much
for watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot a vinspresso
and enjoy the bonus clip
let's pray so give me go
you've mentioned that you've you've been
lucky enough to have mentors in your
life such as Anna Wintour the editor of
Vogue Arianna Huffington
Johnny I've of Apple I'm notorious for
just cold calling people in I just pick
up the phone call them up and let's just
talk you know there's nothing in
particular I just want to talk and just
you know explain to me how you see your
business you know how do you operate the
business you know Johnny eyes in
particular me is just fascinating his
process of creating design and when I
was playing I used what I did that I
used to try to connect the dots between
how John Williams will compose a score
for film or Johnny eyes would design new
Apple product and how does that connect
to how I play the game the basketball is
there's something there that I can learn
that can be used when I step out here on
the court there's lessons that surround
us I mean it life is basically a library
you just you know all we need to do is
just open our eyes and look and and ask
and read accordingly so is that
something you were doing you were
building those relationships even but
outside of your interest as a
businessman really it even as a a fleet
and a basketball player yeah I miss the
curiosity I think the curiosity is the
most important thing I mean it's it's
you know it's sounds really weird to say
but it means like leadership lessons
yeah I learn leadership lessons just
from walking in the park is just
observing nature and the son's
relationship with nature and
relationship with the moon and the Sun
understanding when to be present when
they go away right because as a teammate
it was like dude the sun's out all damn
long you're gonna sunburn a hell of a
lot of people right so if I'm playing
this game and I'm on top of my guys for
48 minutes dude you're gonna sunburn
every single team made there okay so the
certain times was important for the
something to be present at other times
it needs to go away right and but their
life les is s around us at all times and
I've always been extremely extremely
curious about
very frequently we'll ask someone for
instance what advice would you give to a
30 year old just getting started here in
your industry what is the best advice
you would give and just as important I
think you should ask what advice should
that person ignore or what is the worst
advice that you hear repeated often in
your industry what is the conventional
wisdom that you disagree with those type
of questions give you a not to do list
and it is what you don't do that
provides the space for what you can do
anyone who says you should do this the
way I did it without any caveats should
be maybe ignored
in many cases but certainly viewed with
suspicion the the type of mentors who
tend to be the most helpful or those who
don't necessarily give you an answer but
they give you a better way of finding
that answer I'm leaving my second job I
want to start my own company what should
I do and they say well I can't tell you
what you should do because I don't have
enough information which is a huge
credibility point in my mind that they
have the awareness to say that and they
said but if I were in your position
here's how I might think through it so
look for mentors who don't necessarily
give you answers but who walk you
through the process of how they might
think about making the proper decision
given all of your particulars and I
think that's what in my experience
separates a mediocre or decent mentor
from a great mentor if and when you go
to find a coach make sure that they
practice and not just profess not right
right right they're doing they've been
there so I was a personal trainer that
worked at Disneyland as a fry cook and
why as a bouncer at a gay bar because
the gay bar paid more because skinheads
would come in to gay bash and so I
needed so much money that I was willing
to get in fights now I'm not a fighter I
can talk my way out of any fight dude
though it's it's God's gift of
intimidation yeah the the the talking
doesn't work I can earn and then I run
right
and so I'm that trainer who then was
able to open up five gyms make them
successful finally because until then I
was a personal trainer fry cook and a
bouncer a client took mercy on me and
said hey man you're not a closer you're
an order-taker or listen to this Tom
Hopkins tape you didn't close me you
just took my order and that hurt right I
said well you're right I have two two
side jobs people who come to me give me
objections I don't know how to handle
the spousal objection money objection
time objection so I let him walk so I
just take the people who are like how
much is personal training I want to buy
ten sessions great let me take your
order right and so as my mentor Jim
Franco you know gave me that tape and
Tom Hopkins leads to Brian Tracey Brian
Tracy to Dan Kennedy Dan Kennedy Halbert
etc and you know and then I started
learning personal development right
you know to the Tony Robbins and and and
and all of a sudden my mind is opened up
into my surroundings of the people
around me who do I need to cut out
because their cancer is versus who I
need to spend more time with because I
need to rise to their level and all of a
sudden I realize holy cow and these
these are built-in coaches as a personal
trainer one on one your clients are
typically the affluent people right
right so I started asking all my my
clients in between workouts right you
know although business advice here a
little business advice there and I found
that these are people who practice one
guy's got a software company next guy
this automotive company right rental
cars public storage places and man it
was just the best advice versus taking
advice from a family member or friend
who goes I heard it on Shark Tank she's
not practicing it wasn't experienced it
yeah so that's the big thing is to take
advice from someone who's been there and
done that and and if they they're
consulting in your industry but they
come from a different industry I would
tread cautiously yeah okay yeah but you
think everyone should have a coach I
believe so I think so too
as athletes we have coaches all right
try to do it on your own now know if
you've dealt with trauma in your life
whether it's some kind of physical abuse
sexual abuse whatever neglect as a kid
you go to a therapist a good therapist
is a coach yes right you've got personal
development coaches like the Tony
Robbins like the Brandon bouchard's why
not have business
why not have high performance coaches if
you've got limiting beliefs why not have
someone reset your thermostat that mom
and dad had set so low Yeah right or
circumstance of growing up it said solo
we're in it we can't see the trees yeah
I look at it as a coach a good coach is
in a helicopter saying you know you see
a lot of trees but I know if you go up
50 yards that way and then 10 yards that
way you've got an open path they open up
yeah that's it that's what a coach does
he buy you time they buy you speed that
buy you success if you tell yourself a
story long enough you start to believe
it don't you believe you act like I have
Tulsa what a wail out of handcuffed
lightning though Thunder in jail now you
know I'm bad over the last week I
murdered a rock into the stone
hospitalized a brick I'm so mean I make
medicine sick the fundamental key to
success is it can take between 18 and
250 four days of taking action for a new
habit to stick I've created a new course
called 250 for confidence or every
single day for 250 four days I will be
sending you a video between 30 seconds
and 5 minutes long that you start your
morning with around making you feel
confident it's absolutely free check out
the link in the description below to get
access